сьогодні 21 серпня День пам'яті і
поминання жертв тероризму Кому як не
Україні і українцям розуміти що таке
тероризм Оскільки у нас під боком
сусідом є держава терорист А в ній
населення це народ терорист який тільки
і закликає щодо вбивства українців
кількість загиблих поранених кількість
людей які втратили домівки прояви
етноциду екоциду прояви переслідувань
депортації це все що робить Московська
Федерація сьогодні з Україною тому Я
закликаю усіх підписати сьогодні петицію
до Ентоні блінкіна з проханням визнати
Московську федерацію так звану Росію
державою терористом Вона має понести
повну відповідальність за свої злочинні
дії